Transcription: Noémie B
Relecteur: eric vautier
Il s'agit ici d'un plaidoyer
pour un cinéma industriel.
En fait, je vais m’adresser
à tous ceux qui
ont un pouvoir décisionnel,
un pouvoir de sortir de l’argent,
un pouvoir d’aider un cinéma
qui peut naître dans notre pays
et dans notre province.
Je vais vous faire une confidence,
qui n’en est plus une.
J’ai fait mes études de communication
à Louvain-la-Neuve, en Belgique.
Avant de revenir ici,
j’avais un vieux professeur,
qui était mon promoteur de thèse.
Je lui ai fait la promesse
de créer le cinéma là où j’allais vivre.
Je savais que chez nous,
on consommait le cinéma
et je savais aussi
que l’on ne produisait pas le cinéma.
Je lui ai promis que je ferais
du cinéma ici à Lubumbashi.
Je lui promettais pour lui faire plaisir,
je ne savais pas que c’était si sérieux.
Aujourd’hui, je me prends
à comprendre que j’ai fait là une promesse
que moi-même, j’ai peur de ne pas réaliser
avant que le Seigneur me prenne.
Toujours est-il que
la problématique qui se pose
est que nous avons réalisé
un comptage de production d’images,
parce que c’est l’image qui compte ici,
des images cinématographiques
et télévisuelles
qui donnent l’identité de la RDC
et de notre province.
En faisant ce comptage,
on a pris les télévisions.
Elles sont là, des télévisions locales
et des télévisions étrangères.
Qu’avons-nous constaté ?
Les images à propos de la culture
de la RDC
produites par les télévisions locales
sont à peu près égales.
J’ai fait un échantillon
de cinq télévisions locales
et j’ai pris deux télévisions étrangères :
France24 et TV5.
On a constaté que ces deux télévisions
produisaient autant que
les cinq télévisions locales.
Quelle est la conséquence ?
C’est que toutes ces images
produites par les télévisions étrangères
sont les plus vues et les plus entendues.
On ne sait pas pourquoi,
mais on peut le deviner.
Le public, Lushois comme Congolais,
préfère les télévisions étrangères
pour regarder les images,
peut-être à cause de la qualité,
peut-être à cause de ce qu’ils trouvent,
ce qu’ils recherchent.
Mais voilà, la conséquence est que
toutes ces télévisions étrangères
réalisent des images
avec leur propre regard,
leur propre intention,
leur propre idéologie.
Et généralement, c’est pour présenter
une Afrique, un Congo, un Katanga,
comme ils veulent le voir.
Et ça, c'est important.
Il faut donc
que nous ayons nous-mêmes
des gens qui produisent des images,
qui racontent notre histoire,
qui expriment notre identité
avec notre regard.
C’est toujours une Afrique à genoux
qui demande à l’Occident le pain,
le vin et la bénédiction.
Il faut donc que nous puissions nous aussi
regarder notre Afrique avec notre regard,
avec notre beauté, avec notre discours,
avec notre admiration,
avec notre passion.
Ce n’est pas facile parce que
ces sentiments, ces convictions,
ces évidences,
que nous devons créer tous les jours,
demandent de l’argent.
Je disais que mon discours était différent
parce que nous avons, je dis bien
« nous avons », des grands talents
qui peuvent faire ce qu’on leur
demande, qui peuvent créer,
qui peuvent emballer.
Mais ils ne dépendent pas d’eux-mêmes.
Ils ont besoin d’être secourus
par des entreprises de toutes sortes,
par des industries,
par des bailleurs de fonds, des banques.
Et c'est là notre problème.
Le cinéma, c’est un art,
c’est une technique,
mais c’est aussi une industrie
qui suscite un marché.
On va dire que c’est un art
parce que, c’est vrai,
il raconte des histoires vraies
ou des histoires de fiction
qui sont tirées de la littérature,
du théâtre,
du roman, de la poésie,
un peu partout dans la littérature.
Ce sont effectivement des images
juxtaposées pour raconter une histoire,
un peu comme le roman-photo,
ou comme la bande dessinée, mais avec
du mouvement, de la lumière, du son.
C’est vrai aussi que le cinéma
va rassembler plusieurs exigences.
On aura besoin d’architecture, c’est
vraiment quelque chose de lourd.
On a besoin d’architecture,
de peinture, de la musique.
Donc, c’est un peu le carrefour
de plusieurs arts.
C’est un art donc extrêmement exigeant
et qui demande beaucoup d’argent.
C’est une technique.
Effectivement, elle a besoin de matériel,
et le matériel n’est pas bon marché.
Des appareils photo, des caméras,
des appareils de montage,
de mixage de son et d’image,
mais aussi dans la projection
des projecteurs, des écrans, etc.
C’est encore une technique
qui, aujourd’hui,
avec l’apport de l’informatique,
a besoin de nouveaux logiciels.
Effectivement, l’informatique
a fortement aidé le cinéma
à le rendre moins cher
dans son prix de revient.
Ça ne veut pas dire que
le cinéma est bon marché,
mais l’informatique
a fortement aidé le cinéma
pour que son prix de revient baisse.
Et ce sont les logiciels qui sont là
et qui nous facilitent
la réalisation de cinéma.
Je ne vais pas ici reprendre
la définition de l’industrie,
mais je dis que le cinéma
doit être une industrie,
comme l’ont fait les Américains
en premier lieu.
Ils ont donné à l’industrie du cinéma
toutes les exigences,
tous les besoins
que présente une vraie industrie moderne.
En créant des studios, on va
asseoir ici des producteurs de cinéma
qui ont besoin d’argent et qui l’ont,
des producteurs qui ont besoin d’avoir
la confiance de leur environnement
et qui ont cette confiance,
des producteurs qui ont des connaissances
dans le système politique,
le système économique, le système social
et qui ont cette confiance.
Ici, les Américains ont réussi
quelque chose de formidable,
c’est de comprendre
que si le système réussit,
si l’industrialisation du cinéma réussit,
ce cinéma peut donner de l’emploi,
peut amener des richesses.
Il y a des villes entières qui ne vivent
rien que par le cinéma.
Ceux qui ont compris ce système,
en Afrique,
ils ne sont pas nombreux,
mais ils existent.
Il y a l’Afrique du Sud, bien sûr,
mais il y a aussi le Nigeria
et la Tanzanie qui commence.
Je parle du Nigeria
parce qu’ils sont allés loin.
Ils ont compris,
ils ont repris les mêmes exigences
et ont créé l’industrie du cinéma.
Il y a des studios fermés,
des grands bazars, mais aussi des
studios ouverts pour avoir la nature,
qui sont accompagnés par des industries.
Les industries n’ont pas peur
d’accompagner le cinéma.
Je vais vous dire pourquoi :
une industrie peut avoir
besoin de publicité.
Supposons que nous soyons ici
à Lubumbashi avec des entreprises
pour lesquelles la publicité est
quelque chose de très important.
Les annonceurs viennent
et donnent une publicité locale.
Le cinéma peut aller plus loin, le cinéma
a pour mission de se faire exporter.
La publicité locale va rester locale.
Le cinéma, qui a une mission
de s’exporter, peut ouvrir des ouvertures
aux entreprises dans le cadre de leur
visibilité parce que le film va voyager.
Le film a pour mission de se faire
connaître ici et ailleurs.
Le film se vend très bien.
Le film se vend, comme je le dis,
en salle de cinéma,
en support amovible
ou dans les télévisions commerciales.
Un peu partout.
Le cinéma est quelque chose de formidable
si on lui donne la chance d’exister.
Les entreprises ici ne sont pas nombreuses
et je comprends qu’elles rechignent
à venir en aide aux cinéastes
qui viennent toquer à leur porte.
C’est vrai que beaucoup d’entreprises,
beaucoup de sociétés,
beaucoup de personnes recourent
aux entreprises pour le sponsoring.
Voir venir des cinéastes dont on ne
sait pas encore de quoi il en est,
on hésite.
C’est vrai que le nombre
d’entreprises est faible.
Mais attention !
C’est vrai aussi que le cinéma
et les entreprises sont à l’aise
dans une société où la stabilité
politique et économique existe.
C’est vrai que le cinéma,
que les grandes entreprises,
l’industrialisation, ont besoin
d’une stabilité politique.
C’est vrai.
Mais quand on regarde les autres pays
qui ont fait du cinéma,
ils ont connu de l’instabilité.
La Russie a connu beaucoup d’instabilité.
L’Europe a connu beaucoup d’instabilité.
Il y a eu des guerres.
D’ailleurs, le continent européen n’a eu
que des guerres depuis 1789 jusqu’en 1945.
Il y a eu des guerres
classiques tout le temps.
Et pourtant, le cinéma
s’est bien comporté.
Donc, même si on dit
que l’industrie, normalement,
a besoin d’un terrain stable
politiquement, économiquement,
socialement pour vivre,
l’industrie vit.
Il y a une industrie qui vit
pendant les moments d’instabilité.
Cette industrie peut prendre le risque
de faire avancer son cinéma.
Cette industrie qui existe
peut prendre le risque
parce que le cinéma n’est pas
une affaire à hauts risques.
Le cinéma est une vente d’images,
et l’image, nous en avons besoin
tout le temps.
Si les acteurs, si les réalisateurs,
sont excellents - et il y en a -
les cinémas font circuler des images.
Le cinéma fait circuler les images
comme ne peut pas le faire la télévision.
Parce que, comme je l'ai dit,
le cinéma s'exporte.
Le cinéma a besoin aussi,
pour fonctionner en amont,
d’une production, comme je l’ai dit.
On a besoin donc
des entreprises qui prennent le risque,
des banques qui prennent le risque.
On n’est pas encore habitué
à ce genre de choses
et c’est là le sens de mon
intervention aujourd’hui.
Je m’adresse à ceux qui ont
les moyens, la décision, le pouvoir
de prêter, de risquer,
et de faire confiance
à l’intelligence de ce pays.
Je pense qu’on peut créer -
Il y a une relation gagnant-gagnant
parce que lorsque les trois étapes
sont bien respectées -
la production en amont,
celle qui donne de l’argent ;
la réalisation, celle qui réalise,
celle qui rêve et qui donne ;
et la distribution, celle qui
fait le marketing du cinéma -
si ces trois sont bien en place et
coordonnées, alors c’est formidable,
nous allons vivre du gagnant-gagnant,
comme le fait aujourd’hui le Nigéria,
comme le fait la Tanzanie.
La réalisation ici me montre que
nous avons des vrais réalisateurs.
Je voudrais que -
Ce sont mes anciens étudiants.
J’avais promis de réaliser le rêve
que nous avions fait ensemble,
mon professeur et moi.
Ici, nous avons ouvert un département
des arts du spectacle
où le cinéma est prédominant.
Et depuis 2011, des réalisateurs naissent.
Malheureusement,
le talent qu’ils montrent est exporté.
On ne leur fait pas confiance ici
et la plupart d’entre eux partent
et vont se faire voir en Belgique,
aux États-Unis.
C’est vrai qu’ils sont partis.
Les seuls qui sont restés, ils sont là.
Et leur talent n'est pas des moindres.
Il faut les voir, il faut les entendre.
Aujourd’hui, je viens vers vous pour que,
quand vous les verrez,
vous leur ouvriez la porte.
Ils ont des choses à vous dire,
ils ont du talent à vendre,
ils ont un rêve à partager avec nous,
avec vous, avec tout le monde.
Ce pays doit rêver.
Et les premiers rêveurs,
ces vendeurs d’images, ils sont là.
Et je vous assure que
leur talent n’est pas à démontrer.
La distribution, comme je le disais,
à partir de ce rêve,
on peut distribuer leurs images,
on peut distribuer leurs productions
chez des indépendants,
chez Monsieur Tout-le-monde,
dans les chaînes de télévision,
dans les salles de cinéma
et ici, nous n’avons plus
de salles de cinéma, malheureusement,
mais elles peuvent revenir.
On a détruit toutes nos salles de cinéma
qui existaient ici
dans cette ville de Lubumbashi.
Elles peuvent cependant revenir
si la production reprend
parce que la vente du cinéma -
Je ne suis pas en train
de faire de la publicité en l’air,
mais vous verrez qu’aujourd’hui,
le besoin en images est fort.
Regardez les jeunes qui vont sur YouTube,
regardez les jeunes
qui téléchargent des films.
Aujourd’hui, le cinéma se vend
de plusieurs façons.
Aujourd’hui, les cinéastes sont connus
par les nouvelles technologies de
l’information et de la communication.
Ce n'est pas un pari perdant.
C'est toujours un pari gagnant.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)